2025-118. Motion to approve? No, a second. All in favor? Aye. Opposed? Motion carries
4-0. Item G, public hearing to consider master application number MA21108 proposed general
plan amendment GPA 2104 to change land use designation from business park BP to heavy
industrial H. I. Change of zone CZ 2105 for manufacturing service commercial MSC to manufacturing
heavy M-H conditional use permit CUP 2104 a variance V. A. R. 2. 3. 0. 0. 3 and site development
permit STP 2. 1. 0. 5. 6 to legalize expansion of a pallet yard at 4247 Campbell street which
has APN's 1 7 0 2 5 0 dash 0 3 4 and 1 7 0 2 5 0 dash 0 3 3. The applicant is Francisco Cortez
and Ronaldo Aguina senior planner. May we have a staff report, please.
Yes, so good evening. May your work send in fellow council members. So tonight's presentation
is going to be on 4247 Campbell street. FC pallets is always known as FC pallets. And
so as you can see in front of you is the vicinity map in the star in the yellow star
you could see where the actual property is located. It's in the middle of around the
middle of the city of Herupa Valley south of the 60 freeway. This kind of more zoomed in
view of the project site. As you could see there in red you have the three parcels that
are consisting of of that site and in terms of the location we have it's located south of
Campbell, south of Lindsey, south of Mission and south of Kenneth and it's north of Belgrave
and about, I would say, northwest of Felspar. There's another zoomed in view of the particular
site and kind of divided in there in red you could see the areas that are illegal which
is the two parcels ending in 0 3 3 and 0 3 4. The parcel that is not in red is the parcel
that ends in 0 3 2 which is kind of the legal non-conforming portion of the overall site.
In this particular picture we will be talking about 0 3 3 and 0 3 4 which are the parcels
in red. This is kind of some views from Campbell street. The top view shows the view from Campbell
street looking north. As you could see there you could see some of the issues that are
happening on the side with trailers kind of intruding into the public right of way as well
as on Campbell street. The exhibit at the bottom it's the Campbell street looking west again.
You could see some of the issues there with the high stacks of pallets also ported parties
in the property site. The following slide that we'll be talking about a little bit about
the background of the site as well as some of the actions that city has taken in terms
of code enforcement as well as some of the city attorney actions that have been taken on the
site up until now. To start with in August 21st 2006 there was an approval through the
county time of 18,730 square feet and that is a pallet yard that ends with APN 0 3 2 or
otherwise known as address 4287 Campbell. That particular site became legal non-conforming
over time and as part of the legal non-conforming it does need to be abated by August 21st of
2046. Also this particular site does need to comply also with the pallet yard regulations
per city standards. Since that 2006 approval the actual pallet yard being has expanded
legally expanded to the north and that is into the parcels ending in 0 3 3 and 0 3 4.
The applicant during the county time did apply for a plot plan 1739 to legalize that
expansion in 2012 which was sorry which was transferred to the city in 2012. Since then
the applicant did not move forward with the application which became inactive and basically
closed out. In February 24th of 2013 Cal Fire provided a notice to the city of possible
violations for 4247 Campbell and that includes the two parcels ending in 0 3 3 0 3 4. That
acted into a code enforcement case which they later went to the site on March 19th 2013
and when they inspected the site what they found the site was issues such as commercial
vehicles blocking Campbell vehicles parked in opposite direction of Campbell loading and
unloading on the middle of Campbell and illegal expansion of the pallet yard. I will be showing
a few pictures later on in the presentation kind of showing these kind of issues that
are on the site. On October 3rd 2013 code enforcement issued a notice of inspection letter
basically this letter let the applicant know of the issues that they found when they inspected
the site. Aside from the ones that I just mentioned some additional concerns that they
had was parking of oversized commercial vehicles in residential areas operating business without
zoning approval that is operating illegal business on parcels 0 3 3 and 0 3 4 without going
through an entitlement to legalize them. They also had storage of combustible material
and violation of the uniform fire code. Additionally after that in two separate locations May 21st
2015 and July 17th 2017 code enforcement provided notice of violation in order to comply letter
to the applicant. In that letter the additional issues the structures added on to and large
or altered and these structures were some of the illegal structures that they found in
these two sites 0 3 3 and 0 3 4. Also failure to obtain final building permitted inspections
for those illegal structures that we will be talking a little bit more in the presentation
ahead. On March 1st 2018 the city adopted a pallet yard regulation due to concerns of fire
safety land use compatibility and blight and access. Moving forward March 14th 2018 code
enforcement provided a notice of administrative citation basically this meant that the applicant
was not abiding by the initial notices that were provided and therefore they were added
a notice of that administrative citation at that point. On July 1st 2020 code enforcement
issued a second notice of violation in order to comply letter to failure to acquire building
permits. August 7th 2020 a determination of nonconforming use was provided to the applicant
and this was specifically to parse address 42 87 which was the legal nonconforming parcel
ending in APN 0 3 2. In March 31st of 2021 the applicant submitted entitlement application
for the approval of the pallet yard which is what we're talking about right now and may
2 11 0 8. These are the next is a list of city attorney actions that were taken in terms of the
project site as well. So on January 9th of 2020 legal nonconforming letter was sent to FC pallets
the owner there and noting that the project needs to comply with pallet yard standards
and that's the pallet yard regulations. On November 24th 2020 another email was sent confirming that
only 42 87 was deemed legal nonconforming and that's the parcel that's ends in 0 3 2.
In December of 2020 the city attorney denied a joint agreement that was requested by the
applicant's attorney and therefore the applicant threatened litigation at that point.
On March 1st of 2021 city served a season desist letter due to concerns of fire safety
land use compatibility visual blight and access. Moving forward on November 2nd 2021 there was a
file they complaint for preliminary and permanent induction to abate a public nuisance of the site.
On September 13th of 2024 trial sorry September 13th 2024 was the initial trial for this project
site due to a city not taking action at that point quite yet it was moved until to allow city
action to take place. The trial was moved to October 17th of 2025 at that point city has not
taking action yet therefore that particular trial was moved again to now January 30th of
2026. In terms of the proposal of the site the applicant is proposing to legalize the
expansion of the pallet yard which consists about 0.66 acres which is a combination of the 0.33
APN and 0.34 parcels those two parcels which will increase from 0.43 to 1.09 acres.
In terms of the proposed entitlements the returns that will be required to do this to legalize the
expansion will be a general plan amendment basically changing from business park to heavy
industrial and removing the business park overlay and equestrian lifestyle protection overlay.
A change of zone will be required as well to change from manufacturing service commercial
to manufacturing heavy. Conditional use permit will be needed to legalize the expansion pallet yard
and also a variance will be needed to allow the pallet yard to be within a thousand feet
of the residential surrounding areas. So part of the pallet yard regulations one of the regulations
is that no pallet yards could be within a thousand feet from any residential school or parks so the
applicant is requesting a variance to to be closer than that. Also we say development permit is required
to legalize the pallet yard. In terms of site conditions basically since the applicant provided
the application under MA 21108 and litigation started the city has not cited the applicant just
to let him pro go through the process and go through the litigation process. So the last time they
cited the applicant city did was the March 31st of 2021. The site has worsened since then so it's
gotten worse and so in terms of verifying that court enforcement did go out there to do another
site visit on February 13th 2024 prior to the planning commission hearing and a court enforcement
at that time found in on the site over stacked pallets with minimal or no spacing between stacks.
Part commercial vehicles and trailers sometimes with pallet stacks on the street as well loading
and unloading of pallets in the middle of the street on Campbell encroachment of semi trailers onto
the right of way accumulation of trash and debris on the site such as trash bins and dirt piles
use of storage of port of port of parties or portable restrooms and under unpermitted utility
installations. These are some of the pictures that court enforcement took during that site visit
as you could see here to your left top left you have your portable restrooms report parties that
were found to the right to that you have your parking trailers on the street right with pallet
yards on top of them you the trash and debris along Campbell and the over stacking of pallets
which go beyond the current fencing on the site. Since then the site has remained the same so nothing
has changed on the site in terms of issues that are seen there. Co-in enforcement did go out there
one more time on June 24th 2025 and again it's the same list that they provided in the prior time
it's basically the same issues that they've been seeing on the site. These are some of the pictures
that they took on June 25th as you can see parking on the right of way in terms of vehicles,
parking of trailers again with stacked pallets, unpermitted structures on the site and then you
have over stacking of the pallets on the site. This is what you see in front of you is the site plan
that the applicant provided to kind of go over it the what you see in yellow is the property ending
at 032 as you can see there mentioning it's not part of this particular sub-middle and so in
regards to structures what you see in blue are all the illegal structures that are currently on the site.
Sorry. Did you say legal or illegal structure? Sorry. Illegal. Illegal structures. Thank you.
Correct. So in blue is all the illegal structures which is about four out of the six total that are
within those two parcels there's only two that are currently permitted on the site. Furthermore to
move forward the what you see in red there are kind of the applicant proposed areas of pallet stacking
that's where they'll be having their pallets or they're proposing to have their pallets.
Okay it's it's so the area in red is where they're proposing in terms of where they're going to be
having their pallets. Moving forward in yellow what you see there is kind of what the existing
block wall it's a six foot block wall that's existing on the site and then moving forward from
there what you see in green is what the applicant is proposing as the new block wall that they're
going to be proposing along Campbell that's about an eight foot that they're proposing along Campbell
there. In purple kind of in the shade of purple that you see there is the unloading area that they're
going to be unloading and loading the pallets. This is what you see as the elevation of the
office which is one of the permitted structures on the two illegal expanded butts. This is the only
elevation that was provided by the applicant which did not provide elevations for all the illegal
structures that were on the site. This is the landscaping that was proposed as you could see
there they're proposing landscaping along Campbell minimal landscaping and also landscaping within
the site in green kind of mostly shrubs and plants not many trees. This is a general plan in terms
of what's existing and what is being proposed what's existing currently on the site it's business park
that's what the land uses for what the applicant is proposing is heavy industrial. That alone
probably in the next slide sorry yes. So the next slide here basically there is some compatibility
issues with the applicant proposing going from business park to heavy industrial. The biggest
issue here is that currently business park allows for mostly commercial or retail kind of area as
well as some kind of business park which is more of a employee intensive use compared to heavy
industrial which allows for intensive uses such as manufacturing heavy industrial and that alone
is not compatible with the surrounding area which is mostly residential business park surrounding this
particular area. One of the general plan policies or land uses that the applicant or the project
we need to abide by which I foresee it's not abiding by is basically land use 8.3 that states
retain and enhance integrity of legal existing residential commercial agricultural and open space
areas by protecting them from encroachment of land uses that would result in significant adverse
impacts from noise vibration, noxious fumes, glare, shading and traffic which this particular
project site is providing right now with the site existing and then the use.
In terms of the zoning the current existing zoning is manufacturing service commercial
the proposed is manufacturing heavy so that's kind of what the applicant is proposing to move from.
Again the change from manufacturing to manufacturing heavy requires compliance with the
manufacturing heavy development standards and in terms of the slide that you see right now it gives
you some of the items that it's either not complying with or need more information for staff to
demonstrate compliance. So one of them is height so that's something that the current project site
is not complying with landscaping is another one parking, lighting, truck idling which
we pursued like truck idling signs that need to be on the site that are being provided currently
and property maintenance. In terms of the Pally Yard development standards regulations that the
current project is not abiding by its unpermitted structures, pallet stacking height which currently
the applicant has about more than 12 feet which per pallet standard regulations the highest
a pallet stacking could be is 12 feet so the applicant is beyond that height. You have issues
with pallet stacking minimum separation which per the regulation the min the maximum separation or
it's eight feet which the applicant does not have that's the applicant has less than eight feet in
terms of stacking between pallet yard pallets. Site conditions another landscaping fire hydrant
system as part of their plans the applicant did not provide kind of sites of where these fire
hydrons are located which is one of the crumbs that we do ask for to provide and also the last one
being kind of the major one is pallet yard must be a thousand feet away from any residential zone
school or park. This here what you see in front of you is kind of an exhibit that provides kind of
the distances from the particular pallet yard site and this is in regards to the variance that the
applicant is requesting. So as you could see there the the closest residential home that is to this
pallet yard is about 375 feet in yellow what you see there is all the residential areas that are
surrounding this pallet site. Be aware that some of these sites are also some of these homes are
in illegal non-conforming areas where they're located in a business park zone which are considered
legal non-conforming but the closest one is 300 about 375 feet away from this pallet yard.
In terms of the environmental review because we are recommending the now for this project the
project is exempt from CEQA in this example per guidelines sections 150611B4. In terms of the
project summary there's a few findings that cannot be made for the entitlements. One is the general
plan amendment and change of zone that will create incompatibility issues right. So what we mentioned
was going from business park to manufacturing heavy it's an issue there one because again business
park only it allows for commercial more something that's more compatible with surrounding residential
uses while manufacturing heavy or heavy industrial is not compatible since it allows for heavy industrial
uses. CUP and SCP the project is determined to health and safety and general welfare of surrounding
commercial and residential uses it's susceptible to fire and so as you can see what I wanted to
add here is as an example is unfortunately last last night we were made aware that parcel under
address 4287 which is the legal non-conforming parcel did catch fire yesterday night and so I'll
be showing some pictures of what kind of what's the the aftermath of that. The other thing issue
is heavy truck traffic close proximity to residential uses and commercial uses and compatibility
issues with the general plan basically and so in terms of the variance we did not see any special
circumstances that are applicable to the site to give a variance and these are some of the pictures
that we're taking this morning in regards to the fire that happened yesterday night so as you can
see there on the top it's kind of an overall from Campbell Street at the bottom you see kind of
one of the building structures that were caught on fire and some of the debris there. There's
some more in regards to some of the structures that were affected by the fire as well as until
the right kind of the debris of after the fact. In terms of the planning commission hearing that
took place on March 13th 2024 planning commission did listen to to the presentation and on a three
old vote adopted resolution number PC 2024-06 recommending that the city council deny the
following entitlements which are general plan amendment a change of zone the conditional use
permit the variance and the site development permit. Before I go in terms of the recommendation I did
want to add that the applicant did reach out to us this morning basically asking us if we could
continue this hearing because of the fire that happened yesterday night and that the fact that
they were not going to be able to make tonight's hearing nevertheless we the rest of that does
recommend that we move forward with the public hearing tonight and basically recommend that the
city council conduct the public hearing and adopt resolution number 2025-119 denying MA-2-1-1-0-8
for the legalization of the proposed pally yard expansion and that concludes my presentation.
All right very good do we have comments or questions for staff?
So one just a curiosity you said that some of the homes that live in that are in that area
the surrounding area are legal non-conforming do they those have a timeline as well?
So those would have a timeline per se yes and then they would adhere to the legal
unconforming timeline and that's that's something that we could look at a little further.
Separate topic but yeah I'll we'll touch base again.
So normally when I when I go through a staff report for a project of like this a zone change
general plan amendment there's a lot of aspects of the or everything's complete this one had some
areas that are incomplete or that weren't satisfied by the applicant what why is that and
what was the dynamic and working with the applicant and also yeah I guess
why is it why are some some areas incomplete?
So in terms of the decision of moving forward to the hearing and not abiding in terms of the
required items that was the applicant's decision so we work with the applicant for
for a few years and asking them to provide us details for every submittal
the applicant would keep on submitting without providing or answering those items that we were
asking for at the end of it all the applicant just wished to move forward and and be heard
basically of with what the site plan that they provided at the end and that's kind of the reason
why you see some of the items that were not provided or is kind of a missing in this case.
Okay and he was made or they were made aware that you know that typically those things get
fulfilled before coming here.
Correct. Okay. You mentioned the pallet stacking regulations are those local or state regulations?
Those are per the pallet yard regulations that that we adopted here in the city on the static.
Correct. In terms of the legal non-conforming site is it the same owner and in both in all
three parcels or both parcels? That is correct it's the same owner for all three.
Okay and then has it been the same owner since 2006 or has it changed ownership?
From what we know has been the same owner since 2006 or since prior to 2006 right?
Correct. Okay. And then when did that area become business park? Is that a county inherited land use
or was that did we initiate that? So that's a county inherited land use that we took over in 2011.
And so what made it legal non-conforming if it was allowed before I guess when was that change?
When did that change happen? That was basically in terms of the pallet yard regulations that took
place but before then it was basically county approved it but under their land use from what
we're seeing it's something that would be required for them to get legalized in terms of general
planning amendment in change of zone. So that was before then. So and then the zoning was the same
before like or similar MSC? Correct. Correct. Okay so if it was the same I guess let me re-articulate
my question. If it was the same land use and the same zoning I guess when did it become non-conforming?
I guess when did the the ordinance change or the regulations change so that it becomes non-conforming?
So that I know part of it will be the pallet yard regulations what's happening in 2020. Sorry let me
go back to sorry. And Jo just I'm trying to understand did the rules change on the first
yard? I want to understand the first yard because it's connected. Yeah just I guess when did the
ordinance regulations or or zoning change to make it non-conforming? So sorry here let me get to that.
So it was in 2018 what's that notice? Sorry in 2022 March 1st 2018. In 2018. Correct.
Okay that's fine we can we can move forward.
And in terms of the fire last night that happened in the the legal one or in the
information? In the legal. So well let me shed some light on that. Could you pull up the site plan
and we can be yeah because we can be a little more specific. Pull up the site plan.
I think it'll be okay right there. So essentially the three parcels consist of
the first one on the left which is in yellow. That's the legal non-conforming portion. There is a
building that is if you could turn around if you could highlight the that building right there.
So we believe the fire occurred at the rear of that. It's an unpermitted addition if you could
highlight that. There we go that right no right in there. So that's where a fire damaged that
building. It also destroyed a metal structure right there. And then adjacent to that there's the
rectangular structure that was destroyed. And then in the middle portion which is one of the two
lots that were focused on this evening there and just to the left there were pallets that were
destroyed. So you had the fire actually impact all three. To a lesser extent the northern parcel
to the right not as much but there was still a fire related damage to that as well. And
this morning our code enforcement team as well as our building inspectors went out to the site.
They issued notices of correction for all the entire area as well as yellow tagged it meaning
limited access to that area. Okay and so if I could with Joe's indulgence and raise I think
one thing we need to make clear is that there's were two types of changes that occurred out there.
One was the 2018 ordinance that changed the pallet yard regulations. Okay and then the other
one that made that parcel nonconforming occurred with the county on August 21 2006. That's when the
county approved that use as a pallet yard. And then following that they expanded what would be
the use on that lot into the two other lots. So that's the nonconforming use at that point in time.
Okay that helps answer me. I think Ray made it clear that there's also the issue of the pallet
pallet standards that the city approved in 2018. Okay so the 2018 regulations changed some of the
standards but really it became nonconforming in 2006. So if this person was to remove everything
from the unpermitted yard would he be able to conduct business in the yellow area?
So he would need to abide by the pallet yard regulations still in terms of the yellow area.
If he abides by those regulations then yes he could conduct business on that site.
Okay and then all right okay good. Those are my questions generally. All right with that we
will open the public hearing. You said the applicant is not here but I will ask is the applicant here
to speak on this item? No. Is there anybody in the public wishing to speak on this item?
Also seeing none I will close the public hearing.
And bring it back up here the requested action and I want to make sure we're clear on the action
is to adopt resolution 2025-119 and by approving this we are not allowing the legalization of
the pallet expansion on 4247 Campbell Street with the two APNs. So by voting yes you're saying no
denying the expansion. Is that the way that is correct? Okay I want to make sure that we all
are on the same page here and we're whatever our vote is is accurate we depicted. Any comments
questions up here from the dais? I have a question and then a couple comments. Go ahead for you.
I don't want to take a moment please. What do I do? In your interaction with the applicant
was there do you feel like they understood like the process that they needed to take on and then
just didn't fulfill it or could there have been language barrier or you know just other limitations
that may have you know prohibited the applicant from being able to fully comprehend everything going
on or was it more like I'm not listening I'm just moving forward. So our direct contact was with
their consultant so the applicant did hire a consultant that we worked directly with. So our
conversation with the consultant so the consultant was made aware of what he needed to abide by
when he submitted for this particular project. And I would add to that that they had a legal
team as well so we're interacting with both their legal counsel as well as their
their entitlement processing consultant. So we'll represent it. We feel that it was very clear
that it was well understood and there were still ongoing non-compliance despite that.
Joe can you fill us in because one of the things that would make sense to know is the trial
has been pushed to next year in 2026. What is the trial going to decide?
I would really refer that to Peter on that.
Joe can do a good job with that one. Now the trial will do several things when it will require
that everything on all of those sites comply with the pallet standards so that they pallets
would be separated they wouldn't be able to be so high they need to have the water in place for that.
And then the second thing it would do would be to require that they remove all of their business
and their storage on the two parcels that are not non that are two parcels that they expanded on
to. And the reason that the trial got kicked until next year was their lawyer kept arguing that
well why do we have to have the trial now when this is before going to be before the planning
commission and the city council. And so the judge says okay we'll wait until the council
makes its decision on how to proceed with the zone changes and the legalization of those two
parcels. Was their legal team or attorney available to come today?
They indicated that they were not available this evening due to the fire.
The lawyer contacted Maricella Medican this afternoon and said that he would not be at the
meeting tonight as well as the applicants. Okay just in terms of comments Mayor I'm sympathetic on
local businesses locally owned businesses and so I just I'm asking questions to have my due
diligence and to have a good understanding of it. However I'm not excited about their interest
in removing some of the overlays the question overlay and others that are important to our long
term vision in the community also removing that for high heavy industrial is also something that
I'm not I'm not looking at favorably. So there's there's a lot of things on my mind.
Other comments go ahead Willie. Yeah I agree with the zone change. We've been trying to be
consistent of going from high to lower rather than reverse lower to higher. But I if I remember
right what triggered the standard changes was a fire in a pallet yard and now before this
event to try to change your approval now there was another fire in a pallet yard in that
pallet yard so kind of to me that's kind of I don't know how to sign. But I mean I'm trying to find
things around it as my colleague Mr. Carmano said you know we're sympathetic to some business
and stuff but I mean I I feel had several years to show us good faith in cleaning up or making
it look to a standard and that's a good question you asked was was there any you know barriers or
communication errors or whatever but I feel had several years to to at least show us you can do it
right and even if you're not conforming that way you can show us that hey you're willing to
to to make your business look nice there I guess make it work. So I find a lot of issues with all
of these things I don't feel they they they put the effort to to show us that they want to do
business in the city and and so those are my comments I don't know what else. Okay Veronica any comments?
No I agree as well I think that it is important that we do support small business I'm here in the
community but most importantly one of them we're always focusing on safety of the community
and making sure that everybody's being compliant so just kind of picking back up of everybody else
I definitely agree. All right and my comments are simply that bad actors do not get you know favorable
results typically and you know whether there was a fire there last night or not my question would have
been when is the last time code enforcement went out there you went out there this morning
and you've seen other issues aside from because of the fire you went out there and found additional
things this company that's operating this facility is doing so and putting the residents that live
next door and the businesses next door at risk you know imagine if he didn't own those other
two parcels then he would have destroyed somebody else's property last night and that's not okay
that's not okay so I think I know where this is heading and we will call for a motion to adopt
resolution number 2025-119 which denies the expansion do I have a motion from somebody yeah I'll
motion we have a motion do we have a second one second all in favor aye opposed abstentions motion
carries 4-0. With that we will move to council business item 16a adoption of the economic development
strategic plan 2025-2028